what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and amazon's first season of invincible
has officially ended which is great for
everyone trying to regulate high blood
pressure
or a weak heart but very sad for
everybody else
it seems like just yesterday we were
watching omniman help war woman and the
immortal
find different perspectives in life and
even volunteering to repaint
guardians hq what a guy he even brought
his son mark
to subway to eat fresh oh my god what
what a swell gentleman but now season
one has come and gone faster than
red rush can punch some omni man titties
and good god did it blow our collective
minds
which means you know we had to do that
new rock star's thing
and try to find all of those details
that robert kirkman
tried to hide from us in a trash bag on
a high shelf
i mean i'm no damien dark blood but i am
dark and i have blood so
i say i'm already halfway there halfway
there
halfway there episode one opens with the
big bad mauler twins scary kate and
smashley
attempting to storm the white house and
assassinate the president until
they are stopped by the soon-to-be slain
guardians of the globe a team most
likely inspired by the justice league
animated cartoon series that came out
shortly before
the invincible comic did and also a team
comprised of all
walking dead actors as robert kirkman
the comic creator and showrunner of
invincible also
created the walking dead which is a show
that
has a good amount of invincible
references as well and speaking of
walking dead alums playing brutally
slain characters
stephen young plays our hero mark
grayson and the first shot we see of the
character is
is that dog to strange nope it is seance
dog the jack russell terrier
master of the mystic arts who is very
clearly a parody of marvel's doctor
strange
but is also a parody of science dog
which is the name
of mark grayson's favorite comic in the
invincible comics
and a comic series that robert kirkman
actually decided to publish for real
with image comics which is most likely
why it's been changed in the show just
for copyright reasons and after we get
an introduction to the family matters of
the graysons we find out that mark
grayson
goes to reginald veljohnson high school
which is of course
a huge shout out to the actor reginald
veljohnson who is most famous for his
roles
as police officers carl winslow and
family matters and of course
sergeant powell in die hard and what's
even better is that the school is run by
a character named
principal winslow who is voiced by carl
winslow
reginald veljohnson himself making him
the most powerful character
in the series hell he could probably
even take omni man
by himself
okay probably not but before i continue
i want to make sure to thank bang energy
for sponsoring this video
here we go
i feel the energy coursing through my
veins every can of bang energy has zero
calories
zero carbs zero sugar and zero
artificial colors
every 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine
super creatine coq10 and branched chain
amino acids i'm sipping on the cotton
candy flavor right now and it is
literally just like cotton candy it's
it's liter the liquid form of cotton
candy it brings me
into the past during the days when my
mother used to bring me to the carnival
mother can you please buy me some cotton
candy no empty
you've had too much already listen i
drink a bang when i need to pick me up
in the morning or when i need to plow
through a long video and want my mind to
be alert
check out bang on instagram and get 10
off of your order at bang
energy.com when you use the code new
rockstars 10.
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or just buy a 12
pack of your favorite flavor like peach
mango lemon drop
or rainbow unicorn if you're feeling
magical on the inside
i know i am use the code new rockstars
10 and receive 10
off of your bang energy order that is
code new rockstars 10
for 10 off later on in the episode we
find mark fighting
mahershala ali's titan on his first
trial run
as a superhero while also trying to
think of badass superhero
names in the process because
multitasking is a skill mark likes to
put on his resume
i mean how else do you think mark got a
job at burger mart which is
actually a nice play on bm bowel
movement
one of the names mark comes up with is
ass kicker which is a nod
to kirkman's walking dead character
judith who used to be called
little ass kicker by daryl dixon former
racist
and when mark's father nolan played by
notorious spider-man hater
jk simmons gets tired of seeing his son
look like he's about to rob a bank in
red dead redemption 2.
he brings mark grayson to meet his best
friend and other
favorite useful mark mark hamill well
mark
hamill playing the role of art the
superhero tailor anyway which is
hilarious because both simmons and
hamill have both played characters
who hate spider-man in the past and the
character of invincible himself has
also gotten to meet spider-man in the
comics at one point
and they have the most hilarious
interaction of all time i highly
recommend that you pick up marvel
team up issue number 14. also when mark
brings amber over to his nerd room he
describes the plot to
the underwater welder a graphic novel
written by jeff lemire one of my
favorite
comic book writers doing it currently
anyways while mark is trying on costumes
art tries to move some old merch by
having mark try on this orange and
yellow suit
and while mark didn't really think it
was the right fit for him personally
this costume is
actually eventually worn by the
invincible character bulletproof
in the comics which is a very
significant character down the line so
this is obviously a tease
for what is to come and also this suit
is actually the first design that
kirkman was thinking about going for
invincible before he decided to go on
the more iconic design that we know
today moving on after omniman sends the
guardians of the globe to heaven
hell obviously had something to say
about it because damian darkblood the
underworld's most persistent detective
is on the case and you know he's a demon
because a he looks like a demon but b
because he likes to write his little
blues clues down on a cute little
necronomicon inspired notebook what a
cute man
it's so sad that you have to go back to
hell dark blood is one of the many
invincible characters that
seem to take a lot of inspiration from
dc comics as he seems to be a mashup of
rorschach from the watchmen comics
and etragen from dc comics like even
mark grayson himself looks a lot like
nightwing dick grayson
but even though damian darkblood is a
surprisingly doper detective than i give
most demons credit for
he just can't see dead people the way
that i want him to but do you know who
can
haley joel osmond whose face has been
borrowed
and superimposed onto the face of the
hero burly
in the background of the guardians of
the globe tryouts
and oh my goodness do my anime eyes
deceive me
that man over there next to blackie
barnes why
it's none other than the greatest hero
of all time
but if there is anyone that is throwing
more than one punch it's going to be
invincible villain
multiple the brother of guardian of the
globe duplicate
who is teased later on in the episode
hanging out with his paul posse
in prison on chicken pot pie day and
also while nolan and debbie are on their
cute coffee date in rome the dragon
casually [ __ ] up all of
caesar's [ __ ] in the background is none
other than the invincible villain
mr liu a man who manifests a literal
dragon
every time he falls asleep something
that the viewers get to see in action
briefly
at the very end of the season as they
tease things for what's to come
but speaking of invincible villain
cameos we get a small peek
at elephant man who was a play on rhino
from the spider-man comics
as well as the lizard league who are
obviously plays on marvel's serpent
society
as well as g.i joe's cobra in episode 5.
and of course
episode 5 is the very same episode where
we see mark
and the guardians of the globe get
absolutely dunked on
by battlebees as a result of a secret
power grab by titan
against the techno clairvoyant machine
head who is robert kirkman's take on
dc's black
mask who we of course see in birds of
prey and i also love hamara shala ali's
titan is clearly inspired
by marvel's luke cage a character that
ali has a good amount of experience with
from his time playing the kingpin
cottonmouth
on netflix and of course titan's rise as
the city's new kingpin
has a lot of the same vibes of the
ending of the luke cage series finale
also if you look closely the little girl
that martian man hangs out with before
he is absolutely
omni-murderated in episode one can be
seen
sitting by herself sad and alone at the
shelter
that amber and eve are serving the
homeless at in case you needed to be
depressed today the next episode has a
bit more focus on the hero adam eve
who we find out is actually one of the
most powerful characters
in the entire invincible universe you
know despite nobody wanting to put
respect
on homegirl's name like she can
manipulate reality on a molecular level
like how many white girls do you know
that can do [ __ ] like that well
okay there's marvel's scarlet witch
which i'm pretty sure kirkman took
inspiration
to make adam eve in the first place but
uh how many
mentally stable white girls do you know
that can do that [ __ ]
because i don't know a lot i don't know
a lot and if you're wondering why that
burping drunk boy at the college campus
mark and his friend's visit later on
sounds so familiar that's because it's
just famous voice actor
justin roiland channeling his inner
human alcoholism
rick sanchez from rick and morty before
he gets turned into a cyborg by d.a
sinclair
played by ezra miller who knows a thing
or two about cyborgs because he was
friends with one in justice league and
also a thing or two about assaulting
innocent people
i don't know how that man still has a
job but you know whatever
anyways once omniman decides to come out
of the serial killer closet
he crushes donald's spine which triggers
donald to sacrifice himself
in order to buy cecil a couple more
seconds of time like i was shocked
shocked at this considering that
donald does not die this early in the
comics at all which is very sad because
i love donald he was a very nice boy but
it's also great to see those little ways
that the show deviates from the original
source material so
i'm okay with it rest in peace donald
but speaking of resting in peace
uh do you know who can't rest in peace
the immortal and while being resurrected
by the gross brothers in episode 7 the
immortal inspired by dc's vandal savage
but
a good guy gets some flashbacks that
reveal that he was
the invincible universe's abraham
lincoln the entire time
so you can imagine how being
assassinated by a john wilkes booth
looking omniman could open up some old
wounds
and finally invincible season 1 ends
with the single most craziest
superhero battle that i have ever seen
in all of my days breathing polluted air
a battle that seems to take a lot of
cues from zack snyder's man of steel
like we even see nolan hit mark with
snyder's now iconic
superman punches from the film but
unlike man of steel kirkman does not
hold back with showing off the
graphically gruesome reality of two
supermen
fighting in a city like i knew that this
fight was coming
because i've been waiting for it for
several years but i still managed
to [ __ ] inside of my pants watching this
scene
wow wow i i don't i don't think
i don't think no one's getting a
father's day card guys i don't think
he's getting one i'm thinking
he's not getting a home depot gift card
not that he needs one but
however if you thought that this fight
was crazy robert kirkman
already promises us within the season
finale that we have not seen
anything yet as he teases us with the
vulture my characters
of craig tula and conquest
and no [ __ ] knowing what i know
about the comics their two second cameo
was
easily the scariest part of this already
nightmare scenario
of an invincible episode like ugh
like if conquest is the salty spittoon
then omni man
is winnie hut jr and mark grayson
is going back to winnie hut general
because that boy knows how to get beat
up real good
he's just constantly in just oh god mark
toughen up you [ __ ]
and that's all i'm going to say on that
because i don't want to get into
spoilers
but that is it for all of the
interesting little tidbits of
information that i want to cover
with this first season of invincible on
amazon prime what did you guys think of
the season like are you guys
hyped that it just got renewed for two
more seasons because i am but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video and please support new rockstars
by checking out our dope shirts
at noon rockstarsmerch.com a lot of
amazing stuff on there and follow me
everywhere you can find me on social
media at mastertainment but
more importantly follow new rockstars
everywhere you can find us on social
media please subscribe to us on youtube
and hit that notification bell so you
can get all the notifications for
whenever
we upload dope [ __ ] because that's all
we do 24 7
365 there is not a time in which we are
alive that we do not make dope [ __ ]
even in the toilet thanks again for
watching everybody take it easy
[Music]
you